yeah i should probably just admit up
front i'm a sucker for a heist
time heist this is one
uh again another one i haven't rewatched
uh
in a long time and one that my memory of
it was that
it's fine it's pretty good and having
re-watched it again
it's a little bit better than uh pretty
good but not
much better than pretty good i mentioned
at the beginning and like
i'm serious i am actually just flat out
a sucker for heist
i enjoy the assembling of the team
making the plan watching what goes
wrong the twists the turns the things
they didn't expect
the things they did plan for that you
didn't realize that they planned for
because you weren't in on that part of
the plan
i enjoy that sort of stuff does it
always make for really good things no
it's actually usually pretty light and
fluffy but it's a light and fluffy that
appeals to me much like pirates do it's
why i like curse the black spot
so i i am already kind of predisposed to
liking this episode i actually kind of
found myself wondering why i don't like
it
more and i think it's just because of
pacing a good heist
is hard to do in 40 some odd minutes
to get all the payoffs of a heist
to like get to know everybody involved
properly to
get all the planning in to get all the
complications that you want to get in
and not have it feel
rushed to have tension that's not just
people rushing around because
a good heist should have those quiet
moments of like are they about to get
caught i don't know
and i think maybe the fact that this has
to cram into about 40 42 minutes
is why it doesn't quite work as well as
i would like it
to but despite that it is
pretty fun so we've got the doctor and
clara and two people who they don't know
one cyborg and one
i guess involuntary shape shifter would
be the way to
explain what she is suddenly coming to
and
you know realizing well they just
touched memory worms and wiped their
memories and they agreed to do a heist
from someone who they don't know and
they don't know why
and they don't know why they agreed to
do it off you go
get heisten so we've got that in what is
supposedly the most secure
vault ever established in a bank that no
one has
ever broken into ever i think that's
maybe another thing the security of the
bank
other than the teller which i'll come
back to
doesn't feel that elaborate it's just
got
basically the high-tech version of
fingerprint scanners
you know it's a dna scanner like well
yeah but you got a shape shifter
there's these things that are just
higher tech versions of security
measures that i'm used to seeing and
it's just a vault with like what 24
locks
and he just hacks his way through the
locks maybe that's part of it
like the security feels actually
slightly lacks
like maybe they were leaning on the uh
on the teller
a bit too much so yeah let's talk about
the teller
little eyestalk things which is a pretty
cool design and a pretty well made
monster
i don't love when like the eyes come
together there's something about the
idea
that he's staring at his own eyeball
that just strikes me as
goofy to kind of have
like the because he's basically going
cross-eyed
to use his superpowers i can't help but
think that when i see those scenes
like that that doesn't work for me great
but that that was a
you know that was a decision in terms of
how they were going to execute it but
like the overall look
and the and the uh feel and the
and the build on the animatronics
involve good stuff
well put together i dig it um i also
really like the reveals at the very end
about
why they're doing this it and
that said i feel like they shouldn't
have called the episode time heist
given that the doctor saying this isn't
just a bank heist it's a time heist
something they could said like 30
minutes in
and he says it like it's a big
revelation that this isn't working the
way he thought it did
except you know that's the name of the
episode dude we figured
time was gonna figure into this somehow
so
i think that might have been another
another minor misstep
but i like the idea that the reason
all of this is being done is
ultimately to free the teller
and his mate so a little bit like hyde
we have the big scary monster just wants
to be with its partner
which yay um i liked it and hide i like
it here
so i like the idea that what sparks all
this
and kicks off this wonderfully closed
loop time circle of a story and
i know i complained about closed loop
paradoxical
circular things when i talk about listen
but that was because of a single
element in the thing that was bugging me
this it's the whole plot
so everything is encapsulated within the
circle as opposed to this plot that's
going on oh and there's a little circle
here which is what happened with listen
uh anyways so i love the idea that he
just gives his phone number
to the head of this bank and says one
day
you are gonna feel guilty for what you
have done and what you are doing and you
will want to do
something to make amends for some of it
even if it's a small way and it's not
enough to fix everything but you'll want
to do
something and when that day comes you
call me
and so i like the idea that she
basically
hired them to rob herself
to try and make some degree of amends to
the extent of which he'd
wronged the teller wrong to this
creature
so i think that's a really that's a
really cool ending twist the idea that
the architect was the doctor
is a little bit less uh clever i think
it
thinks it's as clever as that uh ending
bit with carabraxos but
it isn't quite that sad i do actually
kind of like the way that the doctor
comes to realize that
the architect is him because
they have this thing where you know you
you're unnerved looking at your
own face and like this woman hates her
clones and he's like
i hate the architect so it's
me which is actually not even a fresh
thing because
we came this came up in amy's choice
with the dream master where the doctor
says i know who you are g master's like
no you don't
he's like yes i do only one person in
the universe hates me as much as you do
and it was himself so it is
interesting that they are keeping that
thread going especially
now that they've basically resolved
um the end of the time war at least it
resolved
that the doctor did not wipe out
his own people the way he thought he did
because when he said that line
in amy's choice when the 11th doctor
said to the dream lord
he thought he he still thought that he'd
wiped out gallifrey
killed everyone but he didn't
and the 12th doctor knows that
but he still hates himself
and he still latches on to that fact as
how he figures out that the architect
was him
and i find that kind of interesting and
also
very relatable
because even if
he's come to the realization that what
he thought he did
he didn't do and he doesn't have to beat
himself up for that specific thing
anymore
if you've got a lot of self-ingrained
hatred
finding out that one specific thing even
if it's like the big
thing that you beat yourself up for
doing
you know didn't wasn't as bad as you
thought or didn't go down the way you
thought it did or
there's some reason to alleviate that
guilt that doesn't mean you're going to
start beating up on yourself
because that becomes a habit and
i like that the doctor isn't just
suddenly
totally cool with himself even after
the events of day of the doctor so i
i don't know if the writers actually put
as much thought into it as i just did i
hope they did though because if they did
it's a nice little touch hidden in this
little tiny little
nugget corner of this story which
cool i dig it overall it's
it's fun it's a heist uh i do like that
it turns out you know they had these
things that they thought were
basically vaporizers you know dissolve
them into nothing but instead we're
teleporters so they realize they're okay
the and actually the whole use of the
memory worms that was also tied up
pretty well as
as well because in order to get around
the teller
they have to not know why they're there
so that they are projecting as little
guilt as possible
so again what could have been just a
very contrived
let's just drop them in a situation
where they don't know what's going on
had a very reasonable explanation
so i think ultimately what it comes down
to mainly is that
is a couple of like little things like
the title
um kind of giving the game away too soon
and
the and the pacing i think
i kind of feel like maybe this needed to
be a two-parter to really
nail the the proper
pacing and the tension and
those moments of having to like stand
stock still and hope that you don't get
spotted like they have one of those but
it's
it's a little rushed it's resolved a
little too quickly
just because they have to cram it into a
single episode i kind of want to see
this done as a two-parter
have a little bit more room to breathe
have a few more obstacles
within the bank other than just the
teller and the vault
and i think that that would have really
given it the the freedom to elevate what
is
admittedly some pretty sharp writing and
some pretty well constructed
you know closed loops of storytelling
it's pretty smartly written it just
doesn't quite have the breathing room to
click for me
as as a heist usually will
so that's time heist have you rewatched
it lately
what you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments
let's talk about it you know all the
usual stuff to do
likes and subscribes and shares and
comments and
i have patreon and twitter and a book
and an amazon wishlist and all sorts of
stuff
links in the description go ahead click
on them see where they take you
but also you know you don't have to end
of the day
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings
and until next time this council is
[Music]
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]